depuis new york avec chad week mot aux
journalistes politiques c'est notre
rubrique vu de l'extérieur ce soir
bonsoir
chadwick mot merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france un an donc après la
mort de georges des feuilles est ce
qu'on peut dire que cette affaire a
suscité un véritable sursaut en cuir
assisté a eu un véritable avant et après
nos amis me sortez us à beaulieu sims a
fait la même chose il ya plusieurs
années lorsque le parti de la classe et
master est apparu les de cette hystérie
anti racistes avant les élections donc
cela continue encore mais ce qui est
arrivé c'est différent on parle de la
violence chat contre les noirs par la
police mais c'est que pour une fois
c'est qu'on demande
en fait la conséquence c'est qu'il faut
des finances et la police illuminé la
police dans les états unis et le
résultat ce qui est une hausse très
forte des crimes violents dans toute
l'étendue de notre actu il ya une baisse
importante de la qualité de vie dans les
villes à cela rend la vie pire pour tout
le monde
ce que ces militants ne comprennent pas
c'est qu'ils ne regardent pas les
statistiques de crime
ils ne savent pas ce que c'est que la
police ne se connaissent pas les
formations policières justel des
théories du complot esprits et les
dirigeants de ces villes sont terrifiés
de ces gens devant eux et
c'est par cette à leurs demandes en
compte ce qui permet à une ville d'être
sécurisée pour tout le monde
est-ce que pas rien ça a tout de même
provoqué un changement au sein de la
police
il ya du changement dans la pollution et
un changement négatif
beaucoup d'officiers de police ont
démissionné sont partis à la retraite
anticipée cela est arrivé à lima police
également à new york
j'ai parlé à des officiers de police à
new york et qui m'ont dit t'as oublié
tout ce qu'il savait sur la police et la
police des vitres cassées et c'est à
dire qu'il s'agissait de s'occuper de
problèmes de qualité de fille de
problèmes de sécurité générale mardi qu'
il ne faut plus faire la complice comme
ça maintenant elle les policiers sont
des cibles et policiers doivent être
très prudents lorsqu ils s'utilisent
lorsqu'ils font usage de la force et du
coup la police de vienne devient moins
raide il ya moins d'engagement la police
est nulle plus haute en mesure de faire
son travail a car elle a peur d'être la
cible de foule elle a peur de se faire
mettre à la porte
elle a peur d'être filmé dans des actes
qui ne sont peut-être pas il est beau
mais qui ont l'air au pays est donc
effectivement le travail de la police a
changé des finances et la police à se
rendre quand on sait que c'est une très
mauvaise idée
cela est déjà arrivé dans cet état la
police l'a la ville a promis de diminuer
le budget de la police et font en fait
le contraire car il
on compte que la criminalité se renforce
dans leur circonscription et qu' il n'y
a que la police pour gérer le problème
alors la famille floyd est en tout cas
elle est devenue en un an un ambassadeur
très efficace en de cette lutte contre
les violences policières
aux etats unis la famille qui va être
reçue demain d'ailleurs par joe biden
qu'est ce que ça dit flatté que je ne
parle pas de la fois où il a pointé une
arme mais contre une femme enceinte et a
été arrêté pour cela il a été vraiment
senti fier sa famille a reçu beaucoup
d'argent de la ville de minneapolis
la maison blanche veut être montrée
comme étant supporter yves de cette
famille mais ce qui se passe vraiment ce
qui change c'est que la situation
s'améliore pour personne sondage récent
sûr que j'ai remis deux américains a
découvert que 80% des hommes noirs
américains la même occupation policière
dans le voisinage
donc cela note que c'est démocratique
radicaux ne sont pas véritablement la
fois de la communauté qu'ils prétendent
représenter à chicago par exemple le
nombre de crimes commis par des noirs
sur des noirs est très élevé c'est la
première cause de décès accidentel de
jeunes noirs aux états unis et pas la
police ces gens
aucune idée ce à quoi ressemblait le
travail de la police
les morts par policiers sont en fait
très réduit très très petit nombre des
interactions de la police avec un
citoyen pour conséquence un fusil a
demandé c'est tout cela c'est une
question de politique cela n'a rien à
voir avec les noirs ou la protection des
personnes noires pour protéger les
mémoires il faudrait plus de police dans
les quartiers violence des anars sur les
noirs et galopante l'ignorent il ne fait
pas en parler il valait produire une
sorte de révolution marxiste du système
et c'est terrible et personne dans la
presse une soul dans les po crise il
personne nous dira que la grande
majorité était policier cela des
personnes qui a ont de bonnes intentions
personne ne veut devenir policier pour
briser des crânes et donc que ces gens
ne représentent pas l'immense majorité
des citoyens de nos communautés et ne
représente pas non plus l'immense
majorité était noir merci beaucoup chez
quick mot aujourd'hui ce politique
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france